a nationally acclaimed high school
principal is standing by a new dress
code she created not for students but
actually for their parents Carlota
outlay Brown is the principal of James
Madison High School in Houston Texas and
earlier this month she issued new rules
for parents after one mother allegedly
showed up at the school wearing a head
wrap and t-shirt dress Omar Villafranca
is outside the school Omar good morning
good morning and just to be clear the
parental dress code only applies for
this school it's not district-wide and
the policy says that a tire that is
quote totally unacceptable unacceptable
for a school setting will get parents
kicked off campus now some people like
the new rules other people say it just
really dresses down parents the roughly
1600 students at James Madison High
School already follow a dress code
no hoodies no flip-flops and no low
hanging pants teachers and staff also
must look neat and clean and dress
appropriately now similar expectations
have been set for parents like Tamika
Miller this is a failing school you have
other things to worry about than my
attire this month principal Carlotta out
Leigh Brown issued a letter telling
parents they would be blocked from
campus if they wore satin caps or
bonnets shower caps hair rollers pajamas
torn jeans showing lots of skin and
uncovered leggings also forbidden
low-cut tops sagging pants undershirts
short shorts and dresses that reveal the
derriere you are your child's first
teacher out Lea Brown wrote we must have
high standards I did feel a little
almost insulted but if you're just
coming to that school or you get a call
and you're working out and you run up to
the school I really don't feel that we
should you know punish parents for
trying to be involved in doing the right
thing at least that parent is at the
school the letter was sent after this
woman told a local TV station the high
school turned her away because of her
outfit she said that my headscarf was
out of dress code and my dress was too
short
principal out Lea Brown has been
repeatedly honored for her work as an
educator you're an amazed
woman in 2015 Ellen DeGeneres presented
her with a $100,000 check in park for a
homeless outreach program outlet Brown
established at her previous school the
most important thing to me there the
most important thing Allie Brown
implemented a parental dress code at
that school - which won a national Blue
Ribbon award from the US Education
Department in 2008 some people have even
compared this to she's coming in like
Morgan Freeman and lean on me school I
believe that she cares or she wouldn't
be at that school let's hear the plan
for taking care of the academic
standards then perhaps let's say you
know what you know moms and dads can we
maybe up the ante a little bit I really
don't know a parent that would have a
problem with that if it's if it's going
to help Brown and the district would not
talk to us on camera but it's worth
noting that Brown is actually a 1979
graduate of Madison High School and said
becoming principal was her lifelong
dream
Anthony Omar thank you I don't know how
I feel about that dress code it's like
wow it's pretty strong in some ways I
mean look for a lot of people it's it's
hard just getting everybody out the door
ya know I'm getting dressed herself like
what the woman said at the end it's like
wit just ask parents to you know up the
ante a little bit right